donc je suis Nadia lazoni hein je suis
journaliste aux médias qui est la
première web télé indépendant de
véritablement inclusive puisqu'il est le
seul média aujourd'hui à avoir recruté
une journaliste qui porte un foulard à
l'antenne dans un contexte ou certains
diabolisent invisibilise et où les
françaises qui ont choisi d'arborer un
couvre-chef quel qu'il soit son
discriminés dans un pays laïque qui
garantit la liberté de religion la
liberté de conscience et celle de
manifester publiquement ses convictions
alors monsieur le ministre vous qui
normalement être censé et garantir la
sécurité des personnes vous mettez au
contraire en danger les Françaises de
confession des Françaises et les
Français de confession musulmanes en
votant la loi séparatisme qui stigmatise
violemment tout un pan de la communauté
nationale en le jetant à la vindique
populaire je vais vous donner des
exemples agressions physiques à
l'encontre des femmes qui portent le
foulard mosquée ce qui est incendié
tombe profanée alors tout ceci n'est que
la conséquence de votre politique qui
chasse des imams avec lesquels vous
dignez pourtant encore hier tout ceci
n'est que la conséquence de cette
politique qui vous permet à vous de
fermer de manière arbitraire des écoles
musulmanes et des mosquées sont
décisions de justice et tout ceci en
déclarant que l'islam est un problème
vous dites monsieur le ministre qu'une
religion est un problème
alors moi ce que je pense c'est que
c'est la conception violente de votre
politique qui est un problème et nous ne
sommes pas seuls dans ce malheur je
pense notamment à nos compatriotes de
Corse et dans les Territoires
d'Outre-Mer contre lesquels vous avez
envoyé la police d'élite alors qu'il
manifestait contre la vie chère et
l'augmentation des salaires je pense
également à nos compatriotes juifs qui
ont été choqués par vos propos sur la
présence de rayons cacher dans les
supermarchés j'aurais pu aussi parler de
la violence des violences faites aux
femmes alors monsieur le ministre
que souhaitez-vous que l'histoire de
notre pays retienne de vous un ministre
de l'Intérieur qui divise qui sème la
peur qui sème le chaos et qui parla
détruit le pacte républicain ou bien un
ministre qui protège et rassemble autour
de notre devise Liberté Égalité
Fraternité merci Nadia pour votre
question merci alors madame d'abord
jusqu'à présent je pensais que les pas
d'attaque personnelle et vous avez vous
m'avez attaqué personnellement plusieurs
fois à quelle heure vous avez dit que
j'avais dit qu'il savait un problème si
vous retirez pas ses propos moi je vous
attaquerai en diffamation vous n'avez
pas dit que l'islam est un problème face
à Marine Le Pen vous l'avez pas trouvé
trop molle face à l'Islam et il y a pas
de problème à Marine Le Pen que elle
était trop molle ah d'accord donc c'est
votre façon d'intimider c'est
systématique monsieur Darmanin et vous
êtes même prévisible vous avez limogé
patrons de la police judiciaire donc moi
je vous demande juste de bien vouloir
répondre à ma question
de votre
avec des gens qui je crois depuis tout à
l'heure on leurs opinions elles ont
évoqué avec beaucoup de convictions j'ai
montré que j'étais pas en sucre
j'accepte pas les attaques personnelles
et surtout quand on attaque personnelle
monsieur
répondre merci Nadia merci donc je
constate que vous ne retirez pas donc
acte deuxièmement madame j'ai pas la
même conception du système que vous et
j'ai aucune leçon à recevoir je viens
d'une famille musulmane vous voyez donc
franchement vous pouvez garder vous
pouvez garder vous pouvez garder votre
votre moral dans votre média qui n'est
pas indépendant si je peux me permettre
puisque tout le monde sait que c'est une
chaîne de la France insoumise en très
grande partie c'est moi qui mais c'est
pas très grave quel est l'orientation
politique
de police et vous vous êtes pas
enquêtrice ou magistrates vous permettez
qu'en démocratie on peut se répondre ça
me permet ou alors vous dit tout de
suite que vous avez raison et puis je me
dis puis je passe la question suivante
donc je pense que il faut faire
attention à
mais c'est vous qui créez du séparatisme
parce que votre discours est extrêmement
dangereux mais moi j'appelle au
rassemblement autour de notre devise
de mentir vous travestissez mon propos
j'aurais pu être beaucoup plus embêtant
vous demandant ce que vous pensez du
courage aujourd'hui des femmes
iraniennes que jamais vous ne citer
nulle part qu'est-ce que vous pensez
d'un maire à Tourcoing
pour récolter des voix
madame deuxième diffamation possible
c'est vraiment dommage vous avez mon nom
et mon prénom mais il y a aucun problème
donc aujourd'hui madame permettez-moi de
vous dire vous ne répondez pas à la
question qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
toutes ces femmes iranienne courageux je
ne suis pas à votre place le jour où
tirer
je répondrai à vos questions je vous
pose cette question monsieur Darmanin
pensez-vous être le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui va rassembler et
protéger l'ensemble des Français c'est
ma simple question je protège les
Français en effet et je vous réponds une
question simple manifestement vous
n'avez aucune envie de répondre à cette
question où il y a un régime islamiste
faut le dire et ça et ça rend service
aux musulmans de le dire parce que il y
a des connexions qui sont mauvaises en
effet
Darmanin
c'est quand même pas très compliqué me
semble-t-il de pouvoir dire un mot tout
simple pour le courage de ces femmes la
liberté des femmes de disposer de leur
corps comme elles l'ont retirer et vous
condamnez et vous condamnez le régime
iranien le droit des femmes de disposer
leur corps simple ça ne souhaite pas
porter le foulard elle ne le porte pas
mais monsieur Darmanin la politique la
politique est menée ici en France c'est
exactement le pendant de l'Iran vous
cherchez dire attendez je pense que tout
le monde a vu tout le monde voit que
vous êtes excessive madame vous savez on
ira en Iran on ira on assassine c'est le
ministre de l'Intérieur
Nadia je suis
c'est sexy
on y arrivera pas le parallèle que vous
avez fait madame là qui montre à mon
avis l'esprit
malheureusement extrêmement polémique
avec lequel vous abordez ces problèmes
si vous dites des femmes qui sont tuées
Massac en Iran parce qu'elle retire leur
voile c'est pareil en France avec le mal
en France exactement
ce que vous avez dit non
propos monsieur
darmanination de votre écoute
comme ça il va répondre je veux dire une
nouvelle fois vous avez fait un
parallèle que je trouve absolument
insultant je suis ministre poisson
on répondra pas à la question alors
monsieur le ministre
de ne pas de c'est juste un agent de
paix pour tous les deux
comparer et de préparer l'Iran à la
France madame c'est insultant pour le
pays
Selmane
on finance au Yémen
vous comparez l'Iran avec la France dans
la guerre contre le Yémen monsieur
Darmanin voyez-vous c'est vraiment
dommage d'avoir une telle idéologie pour
défendre une cause vraiment de quoi
parlez-vous Nadia merci Nadia merci
Nadia est-ce que vous le laissez pas
répondre
une question on laisse le répondre comme
ça Nadia comme ça on voit le cheminement
de la région je suis personnellement
choqué qu'on puisse comparer la France à
l'Iran et ce qui se passe en Iran je
vous le dis et ça me choque profondément
et en tant que Français en tant que
républicain ça me choque profondément
madame
de noyer le poisson et de ne pas
répondre à ma question Darmanin
1 je me suis reprise monsieur Darmanin
et Monsieur le
je vous ai juste dit que on est en
France depuis tout à l'heure chacun et
chacune de nos compatriotes évoque des
problèmes et des difficultés auxquelles
ils sont confrontés en France je viens
d'évoquer le problème des Corses je
viens d'évoquer le problème des
populations des territoires d'outre-mer
je viens d'évoquer des problèmes qui
sont assez semblables en fait en tout
cas des difficultés que l'on que l'on
vit au quotidien et vous êtes en train à
moi de me parler de l'Iran vous faites
un hors sujet monsieur Ramadan monsieur
Darmanin
l'abstuce très intéressante pourquoi
vous avez compris comment Monsieur
Darmanin
merci vous êtes exprimé voilà c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué de d'avoir une
discussion entre vous deux mais merci en
tout cas Nadia ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on défend pas le même islam et
manifestement pas la même France
Monsieur ça c'est absolument certain
politique permettez-moi juste de
rappeler aux françaises aux Français qui
sont ici la Mosquée de Paris a organisé
un iftar donc un reniftal c'est une un
repas de rupture de jeûne dans lequel il
a appelé elle a appelé pardon à voter
pour Monsieur Macron est-ce que ce n'est
pas ça de l'islam politique et vous le
savez monsieur Darmanin puisque la loi
sur le séparatisme interdit des réunions
politiques au sein des lieux de culte il
y a quand même des amandes qui sont
prévues dans ce cas-là ça ne vous pose
pas de problème
j'ai un problème plutôt avec le
président de la République
comment peut-on demander à des imams à
la Grande Mosquée de Paris d'organiser
un iftar un une rupture de jeunes à
voter Emmanuel
du complot qui s'applique là
l'invitation elle est visible partout
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes le ministre de la terre et le
ministre des chutes vous n'étiez pas
sans savoir que ce dîner allait avoir
lieu monsieur
est-ce que vous vous voulez bien laisser
répondre permanent en une minute sur
votre première question comme ça on
répond à la question parce que c'est ce
qu'attend de les téléspectateurs ce soir
tout le monde dit voilà et on laisse moi
la question la première question de
Nadia et j'en ai pas du tout la même
conception de la France de la République
et l'islam mais c'est un endroit et ce
qui est bien c'est que contrairement à
d'autres pays vous ne pourriez pas le
dire vous voyez si jamais c'était une
dictature mais dont acte voilà
c'est juste finir comme ça mais faites
de la politique présentez-vous on aura
un débat politique bah vous faites un
peu politique là je pense que maintenant
je pense que c'est joyeuse serait
politique mais vous avez tout à fait le
droit de le faire madame je pensais que
je vois que l'objectivité est pas
forcément le critère premier de votre
analyse ce que je vais simplement dire
c'est que moi personnellement je me
fiche je connais la religion des
personnes que j'ai en face de moi je
respecte profondément les personnes qui
sont religieuses car je ne souhaite
absolument pas définir s'il faut prier
modérément ou pas modérément je le
respecte profondément et il y a ici
beaucoup de gens qui pourraient
témoigner madame supposé rencontrer sont
venus de Tourcoing qui sont musulmans et
qui je crois ou d'une pratique quand
j'étais mère qui est tout à fait
conforme à l'esprit républicain et
personnellement j'ai même défendu dans
le débat sur le voile le fait que je
n'étais pas favorable à interdiction des
signes religieux dans l'espace public
parce que justement en République
française effectivement on peut exprimer
ses convictions comme nous semble sur
l'espace public et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça mais moi ce que je
n'aime pas oui madame dans votre
raisonnement c'est que vous définissez
les gens par ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les luttes
intersectionnelles ce qu'on appelle le
wok c'est-à-dire une identité qui
dépasse celle de la France et de la
République vous définissez les gens par
catégorie les Corses les ultramarins les
musulmans c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
la France la France c'est tout ça à la
fois et que les petits-enfants de France
ne se définissent pas comme petit corps
ce petit musulman petit catholique fort
heureusement heureusement que la France
sait se creuser national où on distingue
pas les gens sur leur religion vous
voulez séparer les gens madame et vous
avez un discours politique extrêmement
dangereux et avec une phrase aussi
simple madame qui consiste à vous dire
est-ce que vous condamnez le régime
iranien qui fait ça où tout le monde
n'importe quel bon sens dirait oui vous
vous me dites ce qui se passe en France
c'est pareil qu'est-ce qui se passe en
Iran vous avez perdu tout le monde a
entendu madame absolument tout le monde
a entendu
cette question peut-être j'ai parlé de
compagnie
cette simple comparaison disqualifie
très profondément je crois MERCI pour
diffamation
merci à vous deux merci Nadia merci
d'avoir posé votre question à Monsieur
le Ministre merci